[La musique]
le premier des neuf avions russes qui
ils débarqueront ici en mer s'entraînant dans le
nuit et amènera environ huit équipes de
Médecins russes parmi les infirmières
militaire et à bord de ces avions qui est
masques matériel il y a des fans
poumon il existe un certain nombre de matériaux
des soins de santé essentiels à
l'action de nos médecins à nous
infirmières de nos opérateurs
santé sociale et je remercie la fédération
Le président russe Poutine et le gouvernement
Russe pour tout le soutien qu'ils représentent
prouver à l'Italie que l'Italie n'est pas
seul à tant d'amis dans le monde il y a
de nombreux pays qui nous aident e
grâce à ces aides le système
les soins de santé de l'État italien peuvent
aller de l'avant dans cette guerre contre le
couronnement
Il est difficile
sur